pues vamos a seguir haciendo algunos
ejemplos de ejercicios muy parecidos a
los que te van a tocar en la siguiente
sección de ejercicios de órdenes de
magnitud ok entonces tenemos por aquí
que el diámetro de la tierra mide
aproximadamente es muy importante sobre
aproximadamente significa que no estamos
diciendo la cantidad exacta pero bueno
el chiste es que el diámetro de la
tierra mide aproximadamente 1 por 10 a
las 7 metros y lo que queremos saber es
cuál de las siguientes opciones podría
ser la medida del diámetro de la tierra
y la clave aquí es darse cuenta que 1
por 10 a las 7 es simplemente un 1
seguido de 7 ceros
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 podemos ponerle unas comas
para que se vea más fácil y bueno ya que
sabemos exactamente cómo se ve esto pues
nos vamos para acá para ver cuál de
estas opciones es la que más se parece a
10 millones entonces empezamos por aquí
nosotros aproximamos de una forma muy
ruda este número a lo más a lo que
llegaríamos sería que está como que a un
millón de metros no a diez millones de
metros un millón 271 mil 543 metros
nunca lo vamos a aproximar como 10
millones de metros cierto entonces esta
opción no es buena ahora vamos con esta
tenemos aquí 12 millones 715 mil 430 y
si lo aproximar a más de una forma muy
podríamos decir que torpe pues ahí sí 10
millones si podría ser una aproximación
de este número porque a ver vamos a
escribirlo con la pasión científica si
quiere saber tenemos por aquí dos
millones 715 mil 430 y bueno si
quisiéramos escribirlo como notación
científica tendríamos que poner punto
decimal por aquel entonces nos quedaría
1 punto
27 15 43 por 10 elevado al haber 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 10 a las 7
ok y si nosotros quisiéramos hacer una
aproximación muy burda pues podríamos
querer simplemente quedarnos con un solo
dígito de todo este número que
represente a este número y en este caso
tendríamos 1 por 10 a las 7 que es justo
lo que tenemos aquí aunque entonces
parece ser que esta es la respuesta
correcta
claro que pues podríamos verificar la
checando el resto de las opciones a ver
podría ser esta opción pues aquí tenemos
127 millones 144 mil 300 metros y por
mas burdamente que aproximamos a este
número connotación científica pues vamos
a aproximar lo por 100 millones no por
10 millones cierto entonces esta tampoco
es una buena
y lo mismo para estados de aquí tenemos
ya ni siquiera son cientos de millones
ahora es mil millones entonces no está
demasiado lejos de 10 millones así es
que tampoco es buena opción así es que
nos quedamos con que el diámetro de la
tierra mide 12 millones 715 mil
cuatrocientos treinta
ahora nos pregunten que 7 por 10 a las 5
es cuántas veces más grande que uno por
10 a la 4 aunque yo eso básicamente lo
que nos está preguntando es si tomamos
puras unidades 1 por 10 a la 4 por
cuánto tenemos que multiplicar a 1 por
10 a la 4 para obtener 7 por 10 a las 5
y eso llama precisamente a la división
ok
este problema es equivalente a cuánto
vale 7 por 10 a las 5 entre 1 por 10 a
la 4 aunque estas divisiones son muy
fáciles
aquí lo que podemos hacer es separar
esta división y tomarla como 7 entre 1
por 10 a la 5 entre
es a la 4 porque estos dos están
multiplicando y se están dividiendo
todos entonces todos son puras
multiplicaciones y divisiones entonces
si podemos hacer esto y sin embargo 7
entre 1 es simplemente un 7 que estamos
duplicando a y aquí 10 a las 5 entre 10
a la 4 pues saber aquí estamos
multiplicando 5 10 es y estamos
dividiendo entre 4 días es entonces nos
debe de quedar simplemente un 10 no
bueno de hecho lo podemos hacer de otra
forma
todo esto de aquí es igual a 10
si recuerdas las propiedades de los
exponentes esto es igual a 10 a la 5
menos 4 y eso es igual a 10 a la 1 que
es igual a 10 entonces esto termina
siendo 70 lo cual significa que 7 por 10
a las 5 es
70 veces más grande que uno por 10 a la
4 aunque 1 por 10 a la 4 cabe 70 veces
en 7 por 10 a las 5 bueno vamos a ver
más ejemplos
ahora tenemos un número 3 por 10 a la 9
y sabemos que es 30.000 veces más grande
que algún otro número y lo que queremos
encontrar es cuál es ese otro número que
cumple con esta propiedad de ser 30.000
veces más grande que 3 por 10 a la 9
entonces tenemos 3 por 10 a la 9 y
sabemos que 3 por 10 a la 9 es 30.000
veces más grande que el número que
estamos buscando entonces lo que podemos
hacer es dividir a 3 por 10 a la 9 entre
30.000
y ahora aquí tenemos una cuestión de
diferencia de notación
aquí tenemos escrito el número con todas
sus letras con todos sus dígitos pero
aquí lo tenemos escrito connotación
científica entonces hay dos formas
fáciles de resolverlo una es escribir a
este número con todos sus dígitos y la
otra es escribir a este número y
connotación científica entonces vamos a
empezar por la primera vamos a escribir
a este número con todos sus dígitos esto
lo que es es un 3 x 10 9 veces entonces
es un tres con nueve ceros a la derecha
uno dos tres cuatro cinco seis siete
ocho nueve y vamos a poner unas comas
para que sea más fácil de leer y está
siendo dividido entre 30.000
30000 entonces encontremos cuánto vale
este cociente ok para hacer eso vamos a
dividir entre 10 tanto el numerador como
el denominador que es lo equivalente a
cancelar los ceros vamos a volver a
dividir entre 10 al numerador y el
denominador y otra vez y otra vez y la
historia no podemos vivir más ceros
ahora lo que tenemos que hacer es
dividir al numerador y al denominador
entre 3 porque si dividimos a este
número entre 3 esto se convierte en un 1
y si dividimos el denominador entre 3
esto se convierte en un 1 entonces
simplemente nos queda un 111 con uno dos
tres cuatro o cinco ceros
uno dos tres cuatro cinco ceros dividido
entre 1 que es lo mismo que estar así
solito
si le ponemos una comida por acá nos
damos cuenta que es 100.000 vamos a
escribirlo para cada 100.000 y por otro
lado si convertimos a 30.000 anotación
científica obtenemos a ver vamos a
reescribir esto tal cual como este tres
por diez a las nueve entre y para
convertir a este anotación científica
queremos poner un puntito por aquí tres
para que éste sea mayor o igual que uno
pero menor que diez punto y aquí tenemos
puros ceros pero tenemos que multiplicar
por 10 elevado a la cuántos lugares hay
al lado de donde quiero poner punto
decimal hay 1234 lugares entonces es 3
por 10 a la 4 y ahora si dividimos esta
multiplicación nos queda 3 entre 3 lo
cual es un 1 por 10 elevado a la usando
las propiedades de los exponentes esto
de aquí nos queda como 10 a la 9 menos 4
pero 9 menos
5 entonces nos queda 10 a las 5 que
definitivamente es igual a 100.000
cierto porque 100.000 tiene 12 345 ceros
entonces nos salió lo mismo en las dos
formas de resolver este problema el
chiste es que 3 por 10 a la 9 es 30.000
veces más grande que
cien mil